I'm just still going through the
documents right now but among the
headlines that the special counsel says
former National Security Advisor Mike
Flynn provided substantial cooperation
with Special Counsel investigators they
are recommending the low end of the
spectrum no jail time possibly probation
in this case the key a document here I
have is what's called the addendum if
you can just come back to me one second
because it has some very important
details it outlines here that Mike Flynn
participated in 19 interviews but
specifically sections of the addendum
are redacted because of ongoing criminal
investigations and I just want to show
you sort of the depth and breadth of the
redactions I in this document here on
page page 2 it says redacted criminal
investigation the defendant has provided
substantial assistance in a criminal
investigation and then you can see the
rest of that is redacted I'm still
pouring through the records but what you
can see here as I said is the bottom
line of the special counsel that the
former national security adviser Mike
Flynn has provided substantial
cooperation he's sad for almost two
dozen interviews with the special
counsel and he's also provided
communications and other records for
ongoing criminal matters which have been
redacted in the publicly released
documents this evening studying a need
to protect the ongoing investigation
Tucker so we have a recommendation on
sentencing for Mike Flynn but also very
strong evidence that the criminal
investigation by the special counsel is
ongoing at this time so just to be clear
the the sentencing that you're referring
to would be for the crime to which he
pled guilty which was crying in the
course of the investigation to him so it
was a perjury charge and he might have
faced actual prison time he yeah he
could have the max for lying to federal
investigators which is a violation of
USC a thousand and one is up to five
years on in this particular case given
he has no prior offenses the high degree
of cooperation it was always expected
that it would be somewhere between zero
and six months with the special counsel
is recommending is
no jail time here based on his level of
cooperation you're right to highlight
that but the other big headline based on
the documents is that this addendum that
outlines how Mike Flynn has cooperated
is heavily redacted as I showed you here
and they've done that because they want
to keep that information secret they
don't want it to be public because it
would tip their hand if you will to the
ongoing criminal matters that involve
other individuals
Tucker girl and their and there's no
suggestion I know you just got these
documents but it's not immediately
obvious to you what he's been
cooperating about or who might be
involved in any of this I'm sorry to put
you on the spot I know you're not
putting me on the spot at all and I want
to give you the best answer I can
without speculating because it's just
too right too important what it speaks
to is that he's been providing
cooperation documents and testimony
about allegations of collusion with the
Russians and members of the Trump
campaign I'm still going through the
documents right now I don't see anything
more specific than that at this time and
that would dovetail with the records
saying they want to protect elements of
the investigation they believe are still
sensitive and could tip their hand if
you will two individuals who have not
faced any criminal prosecution at this
time Tucker well there had better be a
huge crime underlying although there's a
lot of stuff that's redacted I can tell
you they're going through we're really
going through a lot and so if this winds
up just being a bunch of stupid perjury
charges I mean you know someone should
be punished for it hey Catherine thank
you so much you're welcome